باحثون يابانيون نجحوا في انتاج سبعه
فئران من ابوين بيولوجيين من الذكور
باستخدام خلايا جلد من فار لتكوين بويضه
قابله للحياه تم تخصيبها هم ياملون في دفع
علاجات العقم الى الامام خاصه تطوير علاج
لمتلازمه تيرنر لدى النساء حيث تعاني
النساء في هذه المتلازمه من نقص كلي او
جزئي في كروموسوم اكس بينما تمتلك النساء
بشكل عام اثنين من الكروموسومات اكس
ويمتلك الرجال كروموسوم اكس واحد واخر قام
العلماء اليابانيون بمعالجه الخلايا
بطريقه نسخ كروموسوم اكس وانشاء خليه بها
اثنين من جينات اكس وهو ما يمكن اعتباره
عاده خليه انثويه قاموا بعد ذلك بتحويل
هذه الخلايا الى بويضات واستخدموا
الحيوانات المنويه من ذكور الفئران
لتخصيبها في المختبر ادت هذه العمليه الى
ولاده اكثر من نصف درزينه من الفئران
السليمه
[موسيقى]